I meant to go out tonight.
I don't really wanna go out.
I don't really wanna get ready,
but I do need to wash my hair.
I've worn it slicked back for a few days in a row.
And as you can see,
she's not looking that great.
She's looking a little bit greasy.
I think mostly it's product,
but it's probably also a bit dirty.
And then the ends of my hair is super dry.
It's summer here.
I've been swimming.
I've been out in the sun.
And I saw on TikTok
everybody's going mad for that hair mask for now.
And I've seen a few reviews of this.
And so I ordered some because I wanna try it.
Sorry, I don't have my tripod in here
and I can't be bothered going to go get it.
It smells really good
and it's really like very thick,
very viscous.
So I think, you know,
hopefully it should do the trick.
All the instructions are in Japanese
and unfortunately
I don't speak Japanese,
but I'm pretty sure a hair mask is
a hair mask is a hair mask.
So I'm just gonna do what I think I should do. Um,
and I'll let you know.
Here we go. I wasn't sure how much to use,
so I just went with a lot,
a disgusting amount.
It is very silky though.
Uh, I don't know if I said the name of the brand.
It's just NATO
and it cost me $27.
So far I've got high hopes.
Oh, that shower brought me back to life.
I got sent this Dermalogica
Pro Collagen Banking Serum the other day
and yet to made a dermalogic product that I don't like
but this just feels and smells exactly like
when you get a facial.
Okay, so far so good.
I've just brushed it.
Normally my hair gets really,
really naughty,
but it wasn't very naughty
so that's a good sign.
I was thinking about it when I was using it
like what product would I compare it to?
Just like a whole lot of hair on my hands.
Thank you. And it reminded me of the Olaplex No. 4.
I think it's No. 4,
the little one.
Um, and that one's quite pricey.
So but under $30 could be a good dupe
but I won't know until I dry it off.
So give me a minute and I will check back.
Okay, this is how the hair came up.
She's very soft, very silky.
Don't mind me
looking like two completely different people
from the start of this video. Alright.
Um, the only thing that I'm worried about is that
it's so soft and silky
that these curls are never gonna hold.
Running late as per.
But here is the outfit.
I look like I'm off to a funeral,
but I kinda don't hate that
and I still don't wanna go. Anyway,
have a good day.